When I was learning Chinese characters, I encountered too many difficulties, hates, madness, and ridiculous things.
Yes, I said some before, now I will talk about a new one.
If you want to read or write a basic sentence in Chinese and Japanese
Or you are interested in Middle Korea and ancient Vietnam for some reason.
You need to learn these blocks one by one.
So I started to learn Chinese characters. After I learned hundreds of words, I feel that I am getting started.
Then I started to learn (the Chinese characters) different pronunciations, different meanings, and different systems.
There is also a bunch of subsystems... When I was learning, I felt that I was hit by a Chinese character in the face.
Tummy punch
Then another punch on the face
It’s just so bad...
Then the Chinese character big devil suddenly made a fatal blow.
I beat almost GG
That fatal blow is: the pen brush of each Chinese character is smooth!
It was quite simple at first.
They taught me a few simple Chinese characters with only 3 or 4 strokes.
And their pens
So... the first painting?
wrong! wrong! Wrong!
The first painting.
This time is right.
Second painting.
wrong again! ! !
This is the second painting
Ok
The third painting.
Wow, not bad
Then the fourth painting
As my teacher used to say, “almost finished”
Congratulations!
You wrote the word "day"! Congratulations on becoming a calligrapher!
Look at the next one
The first painting... just like the one just
The second painting... The amount, etc., is this the same as before, the horizontal fold?
Yes, that’s it.
Third painting
wrong!
Ok
Then, the third painting
Fourth painting
Fifth painting
Ok, so it seems that there are some rules.
At this time, I thought that this is just a good writing skill for them.
Each word is written in a certain numbered order
But not so simple
It is not just like western calligraphy, just to improve the aesthetics of the word.
After learning, I found that it is actually the most basic part of Chinese writing.
If you don't know the pen is smooth, you don't even know the word
It is sauce purple.
So for example, this way, again, and finally, write a "mouth"
This is the correct way to write
This painting should be written up instead of down
This painting has a small tick up
These strokes should be before these strokes, but other strokes should be after this (the bottom)
This word has 6 paintings instead of 4 paintings.
Then the word has 20 paintings instead of 21 paintings.
Don't mess with this!
We are all watching you!
Fortunately, I thought to myself: Hey, myself.
...I have discovered some rules
Using these rules, I feel so relaxed.
I have made great progress.
Then one time, I saw this (word)
Then, I saw... this (word writing)
So I kept practicing... practice... you know. .
Then the problem is coming again.
One thing you must know is that these laws may change.
I was deeply impressed by the combination of the left and right sides of the left side and the bottom and the next horizontal combination.
It gives me a false sense of security, so I was split and reorganized into complex Chinese characters.
Tortured
Hey, "Song", how beautiful your melody is, but you are a nasty Chinese character.
Moreover, a writing "formula" may apply to a certain Chinese character, but if more strokes are added,
This rule does not apply.
Remember the word "田" that you just said?
It appears alone and appears in other Chinese characters, and the pen brush is not the same.
And in China, the order of strokes is even different.
Chinese people generally have the opposite order of the two paintings.
So if you are in China, don't get confused.
So yes. The pen brush of the same structure will change in different Chinese characters.
And make the pen brush of the same Chinese character different in China and Japan.
The difference between the two countries is not just the order of strokes.
The first time I found this problem, I noticed the word "have".
In China, the horizontal line and the upper part are connected.
Moreover, the word "write" has "bao cover", but this "bao cover" is not like other Chinese characters that I am familiar with.
There is no point above
Moreover, the new way of writing this word is that the old version of Sauce is like this.
In Japan, new styles have fewer strokes, while archaic characters have more strokes.
In China, the strokes of simplified characters are generally much less.
But China and Japan do not simplify the same word.
So the rules I found directly even
Not too reliable
But wit like you, maybe you can look back and see what
The law I didn't notice
These are all the most straight pen strokes
This is just the direction and sequence of writing we have just been arguing.
And when you see cursive and other writing methods
This is the case with a mess of lines and circles.
Then there are more things to learn!
But this is very important
There is a wrong way to write a word, and there is a wrong way. If you mistake it wrong
They will definitely find out
But are you making it?
Hundreds of millions of people are learning how to write these Chinese characters.
You said this is ridiculous? Maybe,.
I did not say that this is impossible.
What do you think of this guest officer?
Write it in the comment area and let me know. And welcome to follow us!